tu vas pas dire un mot de tout le voyage
j'imagine que tu es la fille de la
nouvelle femme de mon père j'avais pas
vu que tu avais des taches de rousseur
petite sœur je suis pas ta sœur même pas
en rêve c'est un petit conique
quoi si ton père venait à découvrir tout
ça c'est quoi ce que tu as à faire il y
a aucun nœud qui me résiste
il faut que tu passes à autre chose tu
te bourres la gueule et tu te tapes un
mec super canon
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je peux pas
me contrôler
que je m'arrête je crois que je pourrais
te résister
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore une fois tu as pas respecté les
règles donc c'est nous qui gagnons je
peux savoir ce qui te prend là
tu m'avais promis
pourquoi j'ai autant de mal à tête
il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
c'est maintenant que commence notre
histoire
elle tend plus les lettres que je t'ai
envoyé
[Musique]